all right speaking of 2024 um in
addition to speaking at cpac donald
trump gave an absolutely absurd
interview to fox news's maria bartoromo
she will not question anything trump
says he can get away with anything he
could say maria
you're now you know whatever he he she
will not question anything uh that
donald trump says and during this
interview trump seems to say he's
running in 2024. we'll get to that and
also effectively claimed that the death
of a january 6 trump rioter named ashley
babbitt
was essentially a political
assassination by a democratic staffer
this is truly dangerous stuff let's get
into it well that's right and i want to
talk about that because ashley babbitt a
wonderful woman
fatally shot on january 6th as she tried
to climb out now notice normally when
people are killed by police people like
maria and trump defend the police they
say don't break the law then you won't
get shot this woman this wonderful woman
uh
the the she she was there illegally
right she was trespassing and if the
situation was reversed they'd be saying
why was she even there of a broken
window
her family has spoken out her family has
been on tucker carlson and they want
answers as far as why this wonderful
woman young woman who went to peaceful
protest was shot
is anything true a piece she was she she
was there criminally and it was not a
peaceful protest it it's terrible that
she died it's absolutely terrible but
this is revisionist history guys any
information there is speculation that
this was a security detail in a leading
member of congress's uh security detail
a democrat what can you tell us in terms
of who shot ashley babbitt what do you
know mr president
so i've heard that i will tell you they
know who shot ashley babbitt they're
protecting that person i've heard also
that it was the head of security for a
certain high official a democrat
and we'll see because conspiracies
conspiracies about what took place
and where is the support of the police
normally they're all about support the
police and then maria bartoromo strongly
suggests that it was a chuck schumer
staffer who shot and killed ashley
babbitt
i i have no idea could that possibly be
true i don't know
but the speculation is very
irresponsible
yeah it's absolutely quite extraordinary
i want you to know that my team reached
out to senator chuck schumer's office
to check on what he may know about who
shot ashley babbitt we have not heard
back from chuck schumer's office we did
send a note and call
yeah what do you think
do you know who it is mr president i
wonder why you know they they talk big
and they're uh real law and order people
when it comes to a certain group but
with another group they can do whatever
they want
one of the most irresponsible interviews
i could imagine and this continues here
is more of this innocent beautiful
wonderful woman stuff yeah that report
showed fbi operatives uh potentially uh
aware but there are unanswered questions
here what did the fbi know
why weren't your cabinet secretaries
briefed what did speaker pelosi know
chuck schumer mcconnell do you have any
answers to that they continue to how
much of a
look at the gaslighting
trump instigated the riots and she's
interviewing trump but it's all about
what was pelosi's role
what was chuck schumer's what are you
talking about all this stuff
and yet no guns were seized mr president
right there were no guns whatsoever and
yet antifa
which went into portland and went into
so many other places seattle they took
over a big part of seattle people died
and there were plenty of guns there by
the way
and in minnesota in minneapolis now in
fact there were stun guns seized
baseball bats flagpoles being wielded as
clubs even against police pipe bombs
were planted pepper spray
and on and on and on um here is
more of trump rewriting history on the
january 6th riots i mean
look at look at what is taking place in
this country
mr president you just referred to the
2020 election i want to refer you to an
article in the federalist over the
weekend and it says new evidence
indicates enough illegal votes in
georgia to tip the 2020 results this is
from the federalists i want to get your
thoughts on what's taking place right
now in arizona and in georgia with
regard to that as what's going on is
nothing
but they're calling them audits continue
to post and discuss election 2020.
that's right well the federalists they
have 35 000 votes and that's far more
numerous times more than numerous we
need to win that state
yeah so trump continuing with that stuff
um and then going directly from
rewriting the election to rewriting what
happened on january 6th and remember
maria has the guy who instigated it here
won't ask about that president let me
move on the fencing around the capitol
is beginning to come down
this week
and this weekend and i know that you
have had some time to reflect on what
took place on that day january 6th
talk to us about
what you're thinking about as you
reflect what happened that day from your
standpoint
so there was a big rally called and
actually when i say big who knew
but there was a rally called and a
tremendous number of people the largest
one i've ever spoken before is called by
people by patriots notice every rally
he's spoken at is like the the one
that's been most attended in history
every rally
and they asked me if i'd speak and i did
and it was a very mild mannered speech
i think has been in fact they just came
out with a report in congress and they
didn't mention my name that's untrue
that report mentions him dozens of times
surely
but what they were complaining about and
the reason in my opinion you had over a
million people there which the press
doesn't like to report at all because it
shows there were not a million people
there too much uh
too much activity too much too much uh
spirit and faith and love there was such
love at that rally you had over a
million people there they were you
didn't have a million people there for
one reason the rigged election they felt
the election was rigged that's why they
were there
and they were peaceful people these were
great people so trump completely
gaslighting saying his speech was
totally mild well you told them to go
and they did exactly what you said he
says they were there for a legitimate
reason which is the election was stolen
which it wasn't and he says that they
were peaceful there were hundreds of
people
known to be committing crimes and some
unknown that are still being looked at
okay real quick two last things and one
of them is trump on 2024 here's trump
lamenting that the supreme court didn't
steal the election for him so this was a
terrible
blot on our country and our country's
history and our country as a you know
free and fair place this you can't allow
this to happen we were very disappointed
by the supreme court because they didn't
have the courage to take it up they
couldn't give you the presidency
and he's mad at pence he's mad at bar
he's met at the supreme court he simply
lost and he can't accept it now here's
the last thing trump on 2024
i think he's saying he's running guys
from what i'm hearing here republicans
against any democrat
they want to do anything they can to
stop that these are dirty players and it
shouldn't happen it's a disgrace
all right so the question is will you
make the run again you said that you
know your answer but you're not
revealing it yet you ready to get back
in that ring and run for president again
sir
sir i do know my answer but i can't
reveal it yet and uh because that has to
do with campaign financing and
everything else you know that so i can't
reveal it yet but i absolutely know my
answer and we're going to do very well
people are going to be very happy
uh and uh look you know i look at cable
ratings i look at the ratings of cnn to
so he says we're going to do very well
and people are going to be very happy i
think he's saying that he's running now
he may be lying he may just be saying it
to continue the grifting to continue
raising money but trump seems to be
saying he is running in 2024. another
bizarre
unhinged interview and hugely
irresponsible
if you ever feel like you just don't
have enough time to read all the books
you want to read you have to check out
one of my favorite apps called blinkist
blinkist takes thousands of popular
nonfiction books and distills each one
down into an e-book or audiobook that
you can get through in just 15 minutes
where you're getting all the key
takeaways from the book just imagine how
you'll be able to expand your horizons
and knowledge by being able to soak up
all of the important insights from 10
different books
in an afternoon obviously it's perfect
for exposing yourself to a new book you
otherwise wouldn't have time for or you
can use it to revisit a book you've
already read or use it to preview a book
before you buy the full version and read
it i recently read a brief history of
time of course by the great stephen
hawking this is a book that i have been
aware of for so long and other things
got in the way and it was fantastic to
check it out on blinkist blinkist has
books on politics philosophy science
they have 27 different non-fiction
categories and a subscription is only
about eight bucks a month and you get
the entire library but you can try it
totally free and get twenty five percent
off a subscription when you go to
blinkist.com slash pacman i've put the
link right underneath this video